it's great we're bringing back the 70s
guys we got inflation conflict in the
middle east
we've gotten emboldened iran we have gas
lines especially coming off of a
pandemic
it's unbelievable how incompetent he is
or maybe its competence just directed in
the wrong direction
in another show of unbelievable weakness
we are now experiencing jimmy
carter-esque gas lines the reason for
this
is not because of actual gasoline
shortages at this point it's because of
this ransomware attack
on a major u.s pipeline it is the work
of a criminal gang called
darkseid according to the fbi the cyber
extortion attempt according to cbs news
that's forced the shutdown of a vital us
pipeline was carried out by a criminal
gang known as darkseid that cultivates a
robin hood image of stealing from
corporations
and giving a cut to charity the fbi said
on monday the shutdown stretched into
its third
full day with the biden administration
loosening regulations of the transport
of petroleum products on highways
as part of an all hands on deck effort
to avoid disruptions in the fuel supply
georgia-based colonial pipeline said
monday it hopes to have service mostly
restored by the end
of the week the pipeline carries
gasoline and other fuel from texas to
the northeast
it delivers roughly 45 percent of fuel
consumed on the east coast according to
the company
it was hit by what colonial called a
ransomware attack in which hackers
typically lock up computer systems by
encrypting data and paralyzing networks
then it demand a large ransom to
unscramble it
so hilariously the white house was asked
about all of this
and the white house's response to you
know what looks like an actual foreign
attack on american domestic
infrastructure
it looks as though their response was
well it's a private problem
which is unbelievable you want to talk
about a weak it seems like kind of
an american foreign policy problem when
you shut down 45 of the gas supply to
the southeast
but here is the white house press
secretary yesterday trying to explain
this away as it's a private decision
whether
colonial decides to pay off the russian
hackers or not so first we recognize
that victims of cyber attacks often face
a very difficult situation
and they have to just balance often the
cost benefit when they have no choice
with regard to paying a ransom
colonial is a private company and will
defer information regarding
their decision on paying a ransom to
them
what do you mean they're a private
company and and like
what excuse me so normally if somebody
kidnaps your child and ransoms them
that's a matter that involves the police
would it not
now you'd want law enforcement involved
at this point but here they're like well
you know i guess colonial
if they decide to pay ransom that's on
colonial
meanwhile colonial said it is developing
a system restart plan
they said that their main pipeline
remains offline some smaller lines are
now
operational this administration is just
a bleep show
they're just a bleep show commerce
secretary gina raimondo said sunday
ransomware attacks are what businesses
now have to worry about and she says she
will work vigorously with the department
of homeland security to address the
problem calling it a top priority for
the administration
she says we have to work in partnership
with business to secure networks to
defend ourselves against
these attacks she says it's an all hands
on deck effort right now we're working
closely with the company state and local
officials
okay you know what'd be great is if
somebody would tell the white house
that it's not merely a private question
as to whether colonial pays ransom here
unbelievable unbelievable
meanwhile gas stations are suffering
shortages all over
the southeastern united states the
closure of that 5 500
mile colonial pipeline which carries
more than 100 million gallons of fuel
from texas to new jersey each day
has stretched now into its fifth day
so it's great we're bringing back the
70s guys all the good stuff we got
inflation
we've got conflict in the middle east
we've gotten emboldened iran
we have gas lines like this this is
really great especially coming off of a
pandemic
again joe biden was handed the most
salutory conditions for any president i
have ever seen entering office
and his immediate move is to blow it all
it's unbelievable how incompetent he is
or maybe its competence just directed in
the wrong direction
meanwhile the good news is the democrats
want to just imitate joe biden's actions
all across the way i mean it's amazing
so joe biden has somehow produced he
inherited
just to get this straight joe biden
inherited a vaccine that works
a vaccine distribution plan an economy
sets a boom and peace in the middle east
and in his first three months he has
produced
deep vaccine hesitancy a dramatically
underperforming economy
inflation gas shortages and a middle
eastern war
really well done here joe biden so
naturally democrats are like what if we
did that so governor gavin newsom
in california announced on monday his
state is projected to have
a 38 billion discretionary surplus in
2021.
now again that's largely because the
federal government has decided to send
checks to all of these states
he said he wants to use it to expand the
state's stimulus program he's going to
send checks to two-thirds of california
residents
california already has the highest
estimated debt of any state according to
breitbart with nearly 363 billion
dollars in liabilities
in 2019 but gavin newsom has a plan his
plan is he's going to send you a check
he's going to send you a check and how's
that this is certainly going to help
with unemployment
in the golden state paying people to
stay home it
certainly it has nothing to do with the
fact that he's being recalled in the
state of california so here's the thing
the economic plans by the democrats here
they don't work but they do work in one
sense
people like free money and so long as
you're telling people they get free
money it doesn't matter because
inflation is the indirect result of a
lot of these policies so long as it's
indirect
you can claim that it's something else
that's causing the economic
supply line problems so that's what
gavin newsom is doing
democrats across the country are
pursuing these giant tax and spend
policies
these horrible policies on crime these
terrible
fiscal policies and then the people who
reap the
who reap the whirlwind are all of the
citizens of these states who then are
lied to by the media who insist that you
keep electing democrats in order to do
more of this stuff
recognize that the joe biden gavin
newsom i think will survive the recall
joe biden
according to some estimates has a 60
approval rating
60 i don't believe that for a second but
joe biden having a 60 approval rating
despite a dramatically underperforming
economy war in the middle east inflation
on the horizon
a dramatically polarized racial problem
in the united states
it just demonstrates that the kind of
heavy lifting the media will do on
behalf of democrats
who are either unbelievably incompetent
or malevolent or both
the biden administration has been a junk
heap thus far
just terrible but we're all supposed to
pretend that he's doing a wonderful
wonderful job he's after all he's a
kindly old fellow
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content